when did you guys first meet though like
at the store at the comedy store a while
ago
yeah yeah i mean the first time you
brought me on stage i remember i was
like
oh he was like well she's getting up a
lot so she must be she's gonna be funny
i guess
that was your intro like i i could tell
you were like kind of pissed like well
she's getting lots of stage time so uh
i know you're gonna like like nikki can
i tell you why
yes i'm gonna tell you why and i'm gonna
be as honest as i can oh no
okay okay okay is is that the comedy
store
used to be uh you there was a rule
where you have to work there and then
you have to
ten years and then you become a regular
and then you'll get spots and
and mitzi pretty much really did that
she was very picky
but fame or people that were great was
not in her
in her register in her brain if somebody
had already made it on her own
she had no interest she wanted to find
people herself
no that's stupid i know it's very dumb
and that's why
no one came to the club we had terrible
comedians
um and so when new people
started coming in right in my head there
was a time where i was kind of like
there's david spade of course oh there's
norm mcdonald yeah these are not restore
people
yeah that makes sense right and so in
the beginning i was kind of like
i know i knew you were funny i knew that
you had
the the ability and and and right and
and the talent
right right but there was a time where i
was like oh well
there goes the store but now
i i rather have it the way it is i love
it
because it's re it made my career
i mean the store is the best place to go
now yeah because without like judd
apatow i would never gotten love
without love i wouldn't got the sitcom
that i'm on now right
and so it put me back on the map but at
the time
when you started going around in love
thank you but i i literally
i just remembered i loved you in love
yeah but i
in my head i'm like it reinvented my
situation
podcasts yeah this podcast is has to do
with
meeting kalila but also the resurgence
of joe rogan and all these people coming
back joey diaz and theo vaughn and
andrew santino and all these [ __ ]
people
dalia so it at the end of the day i'm so
glad but at that time
you know that's how i was bringing
people up wasn't just you yeah you know
what i mean but
that's so funny that you're like yeah
that rings a bell that intro yeah
but it does it does ring a bell but are
my intros good now
oh you have the best well then what the
[ __ ] nikki
i just no i'm just saying that your
opinion of me meant something to me so i
remembered i was like
oh i'm gonna have to prove myself to him
which is fine i get it um but it was it
was kind of
it was because i didn't know that that
was the case
that anyone kind of felt that way but
you were always nice to me i want to say
something like another compliment and it
it might come across as sexist but
we might edit it out i have to just say
what my heart says
i love it and and and um
there's a lot of female comedians that
hate the comedy store
it's a rough room even the energy it's
better now but still
it's a dark room um you have a lot of
alpha males there
um the rooms are tight at times
it's not the easiest room especially the
or
especially during a week night and
anybody that can survive in that
atmosphere also it's got
a stacked lineup so when you're
following five or six
aggressive kind of comedians it can be
difficult
and i always see you do a good job and
also
um it's just a testament to your
talent because of all those elements i'm
saying it's
it's i feel like it's harder for women
like talking to natasha
or morgan murphy and these and these and
whitney's done this show
you know yeah and so it just it's a
testament to your talent
that you can go in there and um
kill deliver your point of view your
style
and um it's you know we welcome you
we we your family there yeah yeah yeah
it definitely
it used to feel that way you're so right
about it being a boys club i mean i
came to la in 2006 and i was go up at
the store at the open mic
uh from 2006-2009 it was not a welcoming
place
for women and there were some guys that
you were cool with and there were sweet
guys that worked
i mean there's always been sweet guys at
the store yeah but some are
psychopaths and they were not nice and
they were bullies and they've been
let go thankfully a lot of them i can
say some names right now i mean yeah i
could i could say some names right now
yeah
yeah i've had some like initials d-a yes
you know d-a d-a yeah
no but i don't know yeah
no i don't want you i'm scared of the
people that i
had that i hate from there like they
were just like so
just the meanest things i've ever had
happen to me was by comics